[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and I'm coming to you from the
Firebase Dev Summit in Berlin.
This is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Android 7.1 developer
preview is now
available on Firebase
Test Lab virtual devices.
Firebase Test Lab for Android
allows you to test your apps
and ensure their compatibility
with multiple device
configurations across OS
versions, screen orientations,
and locales.
The latest updates and
Getting Started tips
are available on the post
linked in the description below.
For more Firebase
updates, take a look
at this great round-up
post with all the details
from the Firebase Dev Summit.
And while you're
at it, also take
a look at the playlist of
sessions from the summit
now on YouTube.
Both of those are
also linked below.
With the links of
Android Studio 2.2,
the time has come to say
goodbye to the Eclipse Android
Developer Tools.
We have formally ended their
support and development,
which means there's
never been a better time
to switch to Android
Studio and experience
the improvements we've made to
the Android developer workflow.
For the latest updates and
links, check out the post.
The original BigTable paper
entitled "BigTable-- A
Distributed Storage System
for Structured Data"
has received the SIGOPS
Hall of Fame Award, which
is really cool.
For a link to the
paper and to get
started with BigTable today,
head on over to the post.
The latest episode of
the Mobile Ads Garage
is all about Ad events.
Check it out to see how to
tap into the Ad lifecycle,
so your app's informed
of loads, click-throughs,
and other key events.
You'll also get a detailed
breakdown of the steps
that occur in the
life of an ad, info
about which classes
and callbacks to use
for common tasks, and
a real world example
of how to put it all together.
Make sure to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Developer
Show."
For some of our past
episodes, click here or here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]